ton amour me donne des belles mais la
trouille de mes yeux je suis pas content
de retrouver ce personnage adore sa voix
sa fantaisie sa folie j'aime toujours
autant ce personnage et je trouve que
même trois ans c'est trop long je dois
faire ça tous les six mois
je vais mettre ma femelle pour la ville
il tombe amoureux
sauf que début du film s'est bien jeté
par sa fille
quand on a des dents pourries comme lui
quand on est il voit comme ça qu'on
parle comme ça et qu'on sent mauvais
c'est un peu délicat de trouver des gens
je sais pas peut-être qu'il ya une
application spéciale pour lui je sent
mauvais j'ai des dents pourries je
cherche l'amour
une fois qu'on a trouvé vocalement le
personnage après tout roule
c'est la création qui est importante
c'est là où tu commences à trouver la
voie où quelqu'un je vais parler comme
ça où je vais parler comme ça où je vais
garder ma propre voie je me rappelle
avoir testé plusieurs voiries ya
vraiment que celle là qui fonctionnait
je veux la paix s'il parle très vite
donc comme il parle vite et qu'il en
peluche is you done
alors parfois qui est compliqué je faire
comprendre mais ça va sinon il ya pire
dans la vie
les météorites qui arrivent et qui
risque de faire exploser tout est de
détruire la planète donc ils vont
réfléchir à un moyen intelligent de
pouvoir détourner la météorite en tout
cas de l'amener dans un endroit où c'est
moins dangereux
le plus gros des aspire aux ide se
dirige tout droit vers le fond qu'on
aille là où les autres sont tombés qu'on
cherche des indices et qu'on trouve un
moyen d'arrêter puis est avec moi c'est
ce qu'on aime dans l'âge de glace c'est
ce qui nous plaît à nous adultes et
c'est ce qui plaît aux enfants c'est
qu'il ya un double regard d'enfant le
voit au premier degré il voit des
personnages s'agitent est tombé glissé
de grandes montagnes s'exploser etc puis
nous on va du second degré on voit des
petites références en voie de l'humour
donc c'est ça qui est qui est
intelligent la création moi en tant
qu'artiste ça ça m'impressionne ils
vivent trois ans avec la même histoire
avec les mêmes personnages
le réalisateur m'a dit qu'ils font
quatre secondes en une semaine
visite du ciu c'était génial j'ai pu
rencontrer le mec qui s'occupe des poils
de sid y passait des mois à faire ça on
nous avait montré comment ça se faisait
en 3d aussi avec de la pâte à modeler
d'abord c'était filmé à prester
reproduit à l'identique c'était vraiment
impressionnant
l'âge de glace et l'eau a tôt ouvert